[Music]
6 12 on your friday morning a las vegas
school leader nevada's elementary
principal of the year state senator
marilyn donderolu surprising pigott
elementary's david hudsick in a
gathering at the school's courtyard
yesterday morning
during his nearly 14 years as principal
of pickett academy david has spearheaded
the transformation of a formerly
struggling neighborhood school into an
award-winning magnet school that is
highly sought after by parents and
students in southern nevada i i wouldn't
be
with this without all of you you have
all we've been a great family we've
worked hard we do what's right for kids
every day and i'm so proud to be with
you state school superintendent joan
ebert also on hand to honor hudson for
his recognition with the national
association of elementary school
principals if you know something that's
cool at school let us know
eightnewsnow.com click community that's
where you'll find cool at school or just
send us an email cool at school at
8newsnow.com john heather
congratulations there's good work there
in the schools